that's also something really good to
know about marriage it's like
you can never win an argument with your
wife like you could if you only lived
with her for one day
right right it's like i won see you
later yeah it's like no no she's there
the next day yeah and then she's being
she remembers that
she does she does remember that yeah
maybe even more than you remember it
you know and it also might be that she
was right and you just out argued her
so you know and that's something that's
really worth knowing too because
sometimes you know you'll have an
argument with
well let's say with your wife and she's
got something to say and it's not very
well articulated
same could be true for you and so you
can just brush it aside
but you don't want to brush it aside
because maybe there's something there
and if you don't address it then it's
not like it's gonna go away man it's
going to grow
so maybe you have to help her formulate
her argument which is really annoying
you know because you want to win
you're having this dispute like i want
to win it's like well
you're not winning that game you're
winning the game
well i think about it as the game of
games you want to win
the set of games that stretch across
time the long war
yeah that's right exactly in the long
run that little battle is not going to
matter
and in fact i i don't you should not try
and be right
if you're right everybody knows it's
fine but there's the worst thing to do
is rub it in
and say i'm right and you're wrong yeah
yeah you do that 100 times and then like
well you're the you're the winner and
she's the loser and then that's great
because now you're married to a loser
i mean you know that's if you do that a
hundred thousand times then your
marriage is over
and then and then they'll be hell to pay
you can be sure of that